all right the three words we had but
we're similar to do you remember what
they were owed you haven't even written
down right there what were they we used
to okay
so the question was I gave you homework
which was to work out what what do any
of these have to do with each other
sure the answer is a lot but what did
anyone come up with a suitable answer
yeah okay so in case you nothing anyone
is in this book but in case you did do
you know maybe just couldn't find the
answer knowing your house won't do
enough about words to work this out all
these words come from the same Latin
base word rights are kind of like the
the grandad of all of these words it's a
Latin word which means Oh homeless
untouched complete so how do all of
these words mean integrity let's think
that integrity
okay what kind of people use the word
integrity we often use it about
character that person has integrity of
character other types of people who use
it are people who are saving the Air
Force or the Navy for instance you hear
captains of ships talk about the ships
or if you watch like Star Trek or
something like that this ship's hull
integrity right what does that mean that
is is is the whole ship is its body is
all together is it in one piece is it is
it you know holding complete or is it
falling apart is it damaged okay so if
they're she's haunting me he's good
it's home it's bad it's like yeah my
wing just fell off I've got bad I'm not
my plane is the whole witty board okay
all right what about
if things are integral to something else
maths is integral to your education okay
what is that actually yeah so essential
essential a good word it's a good
synonym it's a sexual to but essentially
a very specific way right it's essential
to make something complete so if your
education didn't have maths or English
or science either Swahili crucial sorts
of things you would have began a
complete whole education does that make
sense right something integral is
essential and have the whole thing and
of course to integrate me is to take a
whole bunch of little parts right and
combine them shove them together within
hearts are combined into a whole not
what Oh
hol a the grammar something like that
but one complete theme okay sure
what's an integer this is an important
thing you might want to put an integer
is
oh why should you feel stupid
oh that's okay by the way just on that
situation 7 this is a perfect place to
mention it you like I did you teaches
before and later on you do quarter
geometry and then a year a and then you
die and then you tend you do what again
what's up with that and you'll feel like
the same a space you have me now do it
do this before forgotten everything so
here's a drop-by diagram for you don't
have to draw can't if you like some
things you learn them and you learn them
in what we called a linear way okay
you like you learn a there we didn't see
there D and then you get to the ends in
and finished okay but mass is not so
much like a linear way that's is the
wall like a cyclical spiral so the idea
is you take an idea and you go around
and you revisit the same types of
concepts again again but you brought in
your cyclical did I spell it right I
think I spelled right